Salut! Quand on parle de mentalisme on parle souvent de persuasion ou d'influence.
Aujourd'hui je vous donne trois
techniques pour avoir toujours raison.
Alors d'un point de vue déontologique c'est à vous d'être en raccord avec vous-même
et de voir comment utiliser ça ou pas.
Mais déjà le fait de le connaître ça vous permettra aussi de vous en prémunir.
Alors, bon générique !
Trois techniques qu'utilisent les gens
qui veulent toujours avoir raison
parmi la multitude de techniques qui existent.
En premier c'est d'insérer une petite torpille entre les croyances et les valeurs d'une personne.
Cette torpille ça peut être une croyance vacillante qui va remettre en cause le mode de pensée de la personne.
Le but c'est de créer  un conflit interne.
C'est facile d'avoir des valeurs tant qu'on n'a rien qui vient s'y opposer en terme de croyance.
Un exemple très connu c'est le test des "un million d'euros".
Je vous donne deux exemples un peu plus concret.
Un qui concerne youtube vous allez vite
comprendre
et un autre : imaginez dans un quotidien que vous connaissez plus.
bon imaginons que j'ai une valeur, qui est une valeur que j'ai,
qui est de ne pas faire de placement de
produit
pour un produit auquel je ne crois pas, qu'il ne me plaît pas.
C'est ce qui s'est passé d'ailleurs, en 2016 je n'ai pas fait un seul placement de produit.
j'ai eu des propositions, je ne suis pas contre
mais il n'y avait rien qui après utilisation me donner envie de défendre
ou de partager auprès de vous
sur la chaîne.
Mais imaginons pour reprendre le test des un million d'euros
qu'on propose un million d'euros pour faire ce placement de produit.
Qu'est-ce que je fais à ce moment-là ?
Je vais être peut-être tenté de revoir ma valeur
en trouvant des excuses pour pouvoir le mettre en place.
Alors là c'est facile puisque ça concerne l'argent, on se dit ok test facile.
Exemple plus concret : vous avez un pote qui vous emprunte toujours vos affaires,
vous avez du mal à lui dire non
mais le problème c'est qu'il met trois
plombes à vous les rendre,
vous les réclamiez mille fois et en plus il les abîme.
Vous en parlé plusieurs fois avec lui.
Il a du mal à l'entendre même quand
vous argumentez.
Ça ne marche pas trop bien parce que lui dans sa valeur
vous êtes pote et vous pouvez bien faire ça pour lui.
C'est sa valeur, ce n'est pas très grave et puis je suis comme ça,
et puis moi je suis un mec rebelle
etc...
Imaginez vous savez que ce pote est très intéressés par l'une de vos amis en commun qui s'appelle Virginie.
Dans une conversation vous parlez avec
lui et vous lui dite :
" Tu pourras me rendre tel livre que je t'ai prêté parce que il y a Virginie qui me l'a demandé?
C'est marrant d’ailleurs vous lisez souvent la même chose,
vous me demandez souvent de vous prêter les mêmes choses.
Par contre l'autre jour elle me demandait pourquoi le livre était si abimé.
C'était pas cool de ne pas prendre soin de
mes affaires
et du coup je lui ai dis que c'était toi qui mettais déjà trois plombes avant de me rendre mes affaires
mais en plus qui avais tendance comme ça à les dépiauter un petit peu."
Et là vous êtes en train de toucher aux désirs.
Puisqu'il n'a pas envie d'avoir une mauvaise image vis-à-vis de cette personne là,
il va revoir sa propre valeur pour changer ça et qu'elle change d'avis.
Il est obliger de changer son attitude vis-à-vis de vous
et donc de changer sa valeur de base.
Est-ce que c'est clair ? Excellent !
Technique numéro deux : c'est un système que connaissent bien les gens qui prônent l'argumentation.
Il y en a des exemples sur internet, il sont à fond sur l’argumentation.
J'appelle ça la conclusion logique non pertinente.
Vous construisez votre argument dans le but d'avoir une réponse précise.
puisque vous avez une conclusion qui est liée à cette réponse précise et qui selon vous est imparable.
Cette réponse précise elle vous permettrait
d'aboutir à une conclusion logique
qui vous ferait remporter le débat.
Mais souvent vous n'arrivez pas à obtenir cette réponse précise.
Eh bien pour appliquer cette technique
vous devez juste présenter avant
une cause qui n'en est pas une du tout, pour présenter quand même votre conclusion.
Si la personne n'est pas attentive ou si elle n'est pas très courageuse elle ne va pas tout remettre en question .
C'est assez dangereux c'est souvent utilisé et je ne vous dis pas de l'utiliser, je vous dis surtout d'y être vigilant.
Exemple concret : Jean-jacques pour la soirée il faudrait que tu vienne me chercher en voiture chez moi.
Ben non, non je ne vais pas venir ça va me faire un détour.
Ouais mais tu vas prendre quelle route toi?
A cette question tu vas prendre quelle route,
vous voulez l'entendre dire qu'il va prendre le périph
et vous allez amener le fait que ça va bouchonner et que c'est pas bien pour lui.
Sauf que là Jean-Jacques il vous répond simplement
et en plus venir te chercher ça me ferait partir beaucoup plus tôt.
Oui c'est vrai mais par contre en passant
par le périphérique comme tu dis
moi je vais arriver plus tôt que toi en passant par les transports tellement ça va bouchonner.
Et encore s'il n'y a pas d'accident sur la route parce que là tu vas mettre trois plombes.
Alors que si au final tu prends la route secondaire en passant par chez moi,
t'évites le périph donc t'évites les bouchons et tu gagne du temps de l'essence et de la fatigue.
Oh la jolie conclusion qui vient d'une cause que personne n'avait soulevé au départ !
D'une cause complètement fallacieuse.
En plus si ça se trouve la personne utilise une technique de manipulation
dont je vous avez parlé "du pied dans la porte",
qui fait que comme il est venu vous chercher,
bah il va vous ramener puisqu'il a dit oui une fois
ce serait illogique qui
disent non la deuxième fois.
Alors vigilance parce que c'est une technique qui est souvent employée
par ceux qui veulent toujours avoir raison.
Ainsi que la troisième techniques que je vous présente maintenant.
Dans les topic d'Aristote, comme
quoi ce n'est pas récent
dans le huitième topic d'Aristote il est conseillé à l'argumentateur
de ne pas laisser deviner sa conclusion, de ne pas la laisser transparaître
et pour ça il y a une technique de ouf c'est de créer un syllogisme en  mélangeant les prémisses.
Alors un syllogisme c'est quoi ?
C'est une conclusion qui vient de plusieurs prémisses.
Je vous donne un exemple très simple à comprendre :
si A=B et qu'on accepte ce prémisse là et si B=C et qu'on accepte ce prémisse là,
alors une conclusion du syllogisme serait de dire A=C
on ne peut pas remettre ça en question
puisqu'on a admit que A=B et que B=C.
Comme on n' a pas envie que la personne
elle voit directement que A=C,
on va créer un A=B et un B=C en les mélangeant un petit peu dans la conversation.
C'est extrêmement utile si vous savez qu'à la base la personne ne serait pas d'accord.
Reprenons l'exemple de la personne qui doit venir vous chercher en voiture.
"Tu prends souvent le périph toi en fin de journée ? Eh ouai.
Tu perds combien de temps en moyenne dans les bouchons?
Une heure, deux heures ouai ça dépend des fois. En fait il y a toujours du retard quand on prend le périph."
Premières prémisse.
"Elle va être bien la soirée de ce soir.
Par contre je sais que Michel attend que tout le monde soit bien présents pour lancer le truc.
Comme c'est une soirée qui est importante pour lui, ça va être important qu'on arrive tous à l'heure,
qu'on ne lui fasse pas un faux plan.
En plus je pense qu'il le prendrait mal."
Deuxième prémisse.
Le syllogisme est donc :
si tu passes par le périph tu seras en retard à la soirée et la personne va mal le prendre.
Et c'est là que vous avez la solution :
"passe me chercher parce que ça à l'air d'un petit détour mais en fait on arrivera à l'heure à la soirée
puisque en passant par chez moi il n'y aura pas de bouchon.
Alors que si on élargissait et qu'on creusait un peu,
on verrait que peut-être que Jean-jacques il doit partir une heure plus tôt pour venir vous chercher
il va encore perdre une demi-heure après par rapport à la route
alors que s'il était parti seulement une heure plus tôt de chez lui,
il serait arrivé complètement à l'heure.
Il existe plein de méthodes comme ça derrière l'argumentation pour avoir raison.
Peut-être l'année prochaine je vous ferez une vidéo vraiment consacrée,
dédiée à ça avec d'autres exemples concrets.
Vraiment je ne vous dis pas forcément de les utiliser.
C'est votre déontologie là qui entre en ligne de compte.
Par contre si vous avez aimé la vidéo comme d'habitude vous pouvez la liker et vous abonner !
Rendez-vous demain à 17 heures !
Ciao !